le coup en vie humaine des deux côtés il
est extrêmement élevé alors je me trouve
à Kiev donc je vais vous parler du côté
ukrainien vous voyez derrière moi cette
cathédrale Saint Michael juste derrière
moi qui est souvent le théâtre de
cérémonie d'hommage aux soldats tombés
au front et ça a été une semaine
extrêmement compliquée pour l'Ukraine
d'une part il y a eu cette vidéo
montrant l'exécution sommaire d'un
soldat prisonnier de guerre par des
soldats russes et puis vendredi il y a
eu cette cérémonie ici derrière moi en
hommage à DaVinci
code true baliot un soldat âgé de 27 ans
qui était l'espoir de toute une nation
il avait pris des armes en 2014 il était
un des plus jeunes italiens le plus
jeune commandant de l'armée
ukrainienne il avait été décoré du titre
de Héros de l'Ukraine encore une fois le
plus jeune en 2021 il est mort à baroute
il y a quelques jours des milliers de
personnes se sont rendues ici pour lui
rendre hommage vendredi et
cette mort en particulier a été un
nouveau coup au moral des troupes
ukrainiennes mais aussi des Ukrainiens
dans leur ensemble